Aquí tenemos tres problemas,
la idea no es resolverlos,
sino únicamente plantear ecuaciones
que después se pueden trabajar
para obtener la respuesta.
Bueno, para plantear esas ecuaciones
vamos a utilizar proporciones,
déjame ver esto
con el primer problema.
Dice lo siguiente,
9 marcadores cuestan 115 pesos.
¿Cuánto cuestan 7 marcadores?
Como nos preguntan,
¿cuánto cuestan 7 marcadores?
voy a llamar "x" al costo de 7 marcadores,
entonces "x" es igual,
es igual al costo...
costo de
7 marcadores...
7 marcadores..
marcadores...
Muy bien, entonces
vamos a plantear dos proporciones
y las vamos a igualar
y esas proporciones
van a ser de marcadores
a costo.
Entonces aquí tenemos 9 marcadores...
9 marcadores
y el costo es 115,
entonces nuestra
primer proporción va a ser 9,
la cantidad de
marcadores entre su costo,
y esa proporción
debe ser igual
a la cantidad de marcadores
de este lado,
a 7
entre su costo,
que le pusimos "x",
entre "x".
Esta igualdad también se puede
escribir de otra forma,
volteando las proporciones
de ambos lados de la igualdad,
es decir se puede poner como 115,
el costo de 9 marcadores,
entre 9 marcadores es igual a
"x", el costo de 7 marcadores,
entre 7 marcadores,
va, éstas dos de aquí son equivalente pero hay todavía
otra forma de pensar este problema de proporciones
y es haciendo proporciones
de marcadores
e igualarlas a una proporción de precios,
es decir,  podemos ponerle
9 marcadores
entre 7 marcadores,
es igual al costo de 9 marcadores,
entre el costo de "x" marcadores
y por supuesto aquí también
se pueden voltear ambos lados de la igualdad,
así que se puede poner que
7 marcadores entre 9 marcadores
es igual al costo de 7 marcadores,
o sea,
"x"
entre el costo de
9 marcadores que es
115.
Muy bien, entonces cualquiera
de estas ecuaciones es válida
y es una forma de plantear
nuestro problema en proporciones,
después se puede trabajar
con éstas para despejar "x",
pero ahorita no lo vamos a hacer.
Vamos a pasar al segundo problema.
Bueno, este problema dice,
7 manzanas cuestan 50 pesos,
voy a poner las manzanas en rosa
y el costo en azul.
¿Cuántas manzanas
puedo comprar con 80 pesos?
Entonces nos preguntan por,
cuántas manzanas,
esto es lo que no nos preguntan,
vamos a llamarle "x",
puedo comprar por 80 pesos.
Misma idea, vamos a hacer
una proporción de manzanas a precio.
Entonces 7 manzanas
entre su precio, entre su costo,
le voy a poner aquí, entre 50
es igual a
"x" manzanas...
"x" manzanas entre su costo,
o sea si puedo comprar
"x" manzanas con 80 pesos,
el costo de "x" manzanas es 80,
entonces aquí seria "x" entre 80,
muy bien,
otra forma de pensarlo
es hacer una proporción de manzanas,
es decir, poner 7 manzanas
entre "x" manzanas
y eso igualarlo a la
proporción de precios correspondientes,
es decir,
50,
el costo de 7 manzanas
entre el costo
de "x" manzanas.
Muy bien
y claro, cualquiera de estas dos,
también se puede voltear de ambos lados
y obtendríamos otras dos ecuaciones
que también son válidas,
a partir de las cuales se puede encontrar
el valor de "x".
Bueno,
vamos con el tercer problema.
Dice lo siguiente,
una receta de pastel para
5 personas...
voy a marcar en naranja las personas...
requiere 2 huevos...
lo voy a poner en rojo.
¿Cuántos huevos,
esto es lo que nos preguntan,
requiere una receta para 15 personas?
15 personas...
Bueno, aquí nos preguntan,
¿cuántos huevos?
entonces déjame ponerle un nombre a esa variable,
otra vez le voy a poner "x".
Le podría poner "h",
bueno, a lo mejor "h" no es buena idea
porque se puede confundir con una
altura que se usa mucho en matemáticas,
pero le podría poner
"a" o "b" o "t",
lo que sea, pero déjame ponerle "x", vale.
Entonces vamos a plantear las proporciones,
ahora va a ser proporción de personas a huevos,
entonces,
dice,
5, una receta de 5 personas requiere 2 huevos,
entonces 5 entre 2
y eso lo tenemos que igualar,
esta proporción la tenemos que igualar
a
15 personas,
una receta de 15 personas,
¿cuántos huevos requiere?
Entonces la cantidad de huevos que requiere
una receta de 15 personas, es decir, "x".
Y ahí tenemos
ya planteada una ecuación,
otra forma de pensarlo
es con una proporción de personas,
es decir poniendo
5 personas entre 15 personas
y del lado derecho poner
la cantidad de
huevos que requiere la receta
para 5 personas, o sea 2
y podemos...
y hay que dividir entre
la cantidad de huevos
que requiere la receta
para 15 personas,
es decir, entre
"x".
Muy bien y con esto
ya planteamos dos ecuaciones, podríamos plantear otras dos volteando ambos lados de la igualdad,
pero vaya, ya tenemos ecuaciones válidas
para resolver el problema.
Por ejemplo, aquí podríamos multiplicar por 80
y así podríamos encontrar "
x" y con eso obtendríamos la respuesta y se puede
hacer lo mismo en cada uno de estos problemas.
Bueno, espero que te haya gustado,
nos vemos hasta la próxima.